vous l'aurez compris c'est vrai que pour
trouver des remettants il a fallu que
j'élargisse un petit peu mon champ
d'action
je suis allé chercher bombe à un peu
plus loin que les acteurs et les
actrices il a fallu que j'aille chercher
des gens qui gravitent certes autour du
milieu du cinéma mais un peu plus loin
voilà pourquoi pour remettre le césar du
meilleur son je vous demande
d'accueillir ma coach de spa annick
javelot
[Musique]
ça fait plus sûre de moi que fayyad a
enfin réussi quand un film évidemment
j'ai réussi à passer quelques années
déjà comme dans à rentrer dans ta robe
on a réussi à fermer l'oeil du
championnat aller bassar année j'en
étais res personnes je me présente c'est
un peu chiant rocher me présente à quoi
là je reste là bonjour
donc moi je m'appelle effectivement
annick javelot chez 38 ans je pars sur
les 39 ans d'années je les félins fin
d'année tranquille ou pas je suis coach
sportive à la fois préparatrice physique
alors j'ai fait les plus grandes stars
enfin pas que les stars ans j'ai fait
florence cette année évidemment ce corps
un petit peu sec pression' r2 comme ça
on pourrait penser que c'est au nom de
la nature pas du tout non c'est arriver
carrément cubique je vous le dis comme
je le pense
l'accord d'ailleurs je lui dis souvent
influencent toi tu est carrément cubique
en hiver et cubi en été par abreu est ce
que tu te en tout cas ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que lens c'est un bon gros
h caractères gras sa mort fossé ça
d'accord claire et nette savoir
aujourd'hui pour le périnée peut-être
qu'elle perd et n'est pas le périnée
florent train [ __ ] qui sait qu'il a
reconstruit après l'armée promet la
première mise à bas mais c'est là notre
île et qui flottaient partout la
dégueulasse avec le plancher pelvien
les inventaires fait chier réelles
rétroversé pas sur une finition jour les
honoraires versés par sur une inflexion
dans un très bon jeu pas tomber dans des
lieux non plus ce que je pourrais là je
vois des clients mais je vais rien dire
parce que moi secret professionnel à la
préfère il faut pas sévère lagarde mais
bon est clair quoi après eva green a
fallu à faire entrer dans un combat on
l'a fait rentrer dans la soucoupe 1 pour
consignes a quand même un evans déclare
non denis ménochet également denis
ménochet qui lâche tu es des lames
enough le port du pull sur les épaules
dans grâce à dieu attention ça à 16h sur
les trapèzes un petit peu de catéchisme
et en avant pour la nomination et ça
c'est pas grâce à dieu c'est grâce à
keane dans le tableau à l'est voilà la
leçon et demi il ya le sont
effectivement le son est une excellente
alternative à l'avoine ou au blé
d'accord le conseil pour n'importe quel
microbiote sauvage fait des vannes de
coach écoute c'est toi qui m'a dit tu
vas voir ils sont coincés du cul [ __ ]
c'est je peux pas me les encadrer ces
connards dont tu as raison je n'ai
jamais dit ça me tient notre vocal hier
la note vocale à mon genre je crois pas
non
la leçon le vrai bon alors le sont
mesdames messieurs j'ai fait mon taf
c'est à dire que moi quand on me demande
de faire un truc c'est clair je vais
faire d'accord annick y aller comme ça
donc là qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai
pas regardé les films sélectionnés parce
que j'ai pas me faire influencer par les
images d'un flot ya le rapport à la
qualité du son est ce qu'on est en dolby
digital 5.1
j'ai fait une entrée en mono une sortie
en stéréo je suis même allé jusqu'à
repères chez les siens et suivez là
d'accord d'ailleurs en parlant de
perchistes y en a quelques-uns dans la
salle que j'écoute chez d'accord
perchman perchman perchiste exactement
la même chose que chez disent pourquoi
ça fait appel au même groupe musculaire
bien avec mon fils on va faire une
petite démo on est tout doucement sur
ces flexion ferme les yeux on va
peut-être porter une attention à notre
pratique du jour tranquille on va bien
un trop versé le nom de rue à rétroversé
le bassin entre le sphincter ouvrir le
temps accès on va venir chercher na kwa
dans la mia pas cher 1
et là je peux te dire que sur un quai
chie sur un quai chiche avec des scènes
de 68 de cunnilingus très content
d'avoir l'édition solide
[Applaudissements]